Bonjour à tous! Avant de commencer cette
vidéo, Aliénor a une annonce à vous faire.
-Oui, je...
-Une annonce importante.
-Si tu me laisse parler, je dois juste...
-Une annonce qui va changer votre vie.
-N'exagérons pas, mais...
-Cette vidéo est sponsorisée par MédiMoinsQuart,
une entreprise de gastronomie médiévale
dont on vous reparlera en fin de vidéo.
-MédiMoinsQuart! Médi! C'est ma période!
Bref avant tout, aujourd'hui on va parler
de superstitions, de croyances, d'aiguillettes
nouées et d'hommes se changeant en loups.
-Quelle bande d'incultes, vraiment.
-Tu veux dire que la plupart de ces croyances
ne proviennent pas de ton époque?
-Argumentum a silentio.
Et pour commencer donc, d'où viennent les
croyances du Moyen Âge?
-Ben je viens de le dire.
Des autres païens, là.
J'suis on fire aujourd'hui!
-Comme Jeanne d'Arc.
Ok, on reprend: au bas Moyen Âge, bien
que le christianisme se développe, les cultes
païens persistent longtemps.
On trouve encore un culte des sources et des
fontaines au VIe siècle, des sacrifices d'enfants
au IXe siècle chez les frisons...
Certaines de ces croyances sont transmises
via les textes ou les pratiques religieuses
romaines.
C'est le cas de beaucoup de fêtes religieuses
comme celles des Calendes ou de Vulcain qui
sont encore pratiquées au VIe siècle.
L’Église réagit en interdisant de porter
un masque de cerf ou des peaux de bêtes,
puis en interdisant totalement les cortèges
des Calendes au VIIIe siècle.
-Pfff.
Aucun sens de la fête.
-Oui parce que tout le haut Moyen Âge est
marqué par un conflit entre le paganisme
et l’Église.
Les gens continuent de porter des amulettes?
L’Église interdit le port d'os d'animaux
en 813.
Les gens interprètent les rêves? La divination
par le rêve est interdite en 789.
Les gens font de la sorcellerie? On interdit
la sorcellerie dans à peu près toutes les
lois de l'époque.
La raison principale, c'est qu'on cherche
à étendre le christianisme bien sûr.
La raison évoquée et étudiée par les clercs,
c'est le démon.
Le démon, le démon, le démon.
Les potions c'est le démon, prémonitions
c'est le démon.
L'adoration des arbres et des sources c'est
le démon.
Lire l'avenir dans les fientes c'est le démon.
Ah quel champion ce démon!
Qu'il s'agisse de survivances de cultes antiques
romains, celtes, scandinaves...
L’Église considère toute croyance qui
ne correspond pas à ce qu'elle enseigne comme
de la superstition, inspirée par le démon.
Pour Saint Augustin, la superstition c'est:
«Tout ce qui a été institué par les
hommes en vue de la fabrication et du culte
des idoles, tout ce qui tend soit à adorer
comme dieu la création ou une des es parties».
mais aussi ce qui consiste «soit à consulter
les démons, soit à conclure avec eux par
des signes convenus des pactes d'alliance».
Pour Martin de Braga, évêque au VIe siècle,
Les dieux païens tels que Neptune dans la
mer, les Lamies dans les fleuves et Diane
dans les forêts sont en fait...
-Des démons.
On a compris.
-Tu prends tellement cher dans cet épisode.
J'adore.
-Pour remplacer tous ces cultes en douceur,
Grégoire le Grand ordonne de réutiliser
les édifices religieux païens pour les convertir
en bonnes églises mais le synode de Nantes
de 658 décide finalement de détruire tous
les lieux de culte païens, même les arbres.
-T'as vénéré cet arbre? T'AS VÉNÉRÉ
CET ARBRE? BEN TU VAS VOIR.
-Et pourtant...
Certains trucs restent tolérés.
L’Église interdit la divination par les
rêves mais les visions c'est dans la Bible,
ça passe.
Les Européens se convertissent progressivement,
ceux d'Angleterre au VIIIe siècle, de Suède
au XIe siècle...
Mais les croyances païennes demeurent, beaucoup
font leur petit mélange et ne se privent
pas de consulter à la fois le prêtre et
le devin. -Certains peuples germains récemment
convertis sont par exemple pas très partants
pour abandonner les sacrifices, parce que
c'était vachement festif.
Du coup, au lieu de faire des sacrifices à
leurs anciens dieux, ils les fonts aux saints.
Pas sûr que l’Église apprécie.
-Le culte des saints et des martyrs se développe
d'ailleurs, d'après certains historiens,
justement pour combler le vide laissé par
les anciens dieux.
Les gens n'avaient pas l'habitude de prier
les dieux majeurs, dans leur ancienne religion.
Ils préféraient des petits dieux du quotidien,
proches d'eux, à l'écoute, et c'est cette
office que remplissent désormais les saints.
Et l’Église a du mal à faire comprendre
au peuple que même si on peut prier les saints,
c'est Dieu qui est la source de leur pouvoir.
-On retrouve aussi du paganisme dans les jours
de la semaine, que Césaire d'Arles essaie
de christianiser au VIe siècle sans succès.
Cette survivance de pratique païennes est
loin de concerner uniquement le petit peuple
qui mange pas du homard tous les jours:
Redwald, un roi des Angles du VIe siècle,
décide de revenir à ses anciennes croyances
bien qu'il ait été converti.
Chez nous, la reine Frédégonde engage une
chasse aux sorcières païennes soit disant
responsables de la mort de son fils en 584.
-Et la chasse aux sorcières reprend bien
fort à mon époque, mais ça on en a déjà
parlé dans une autre vidéo.
-Et puis certaines croyances antiques qui
relèvent du merveilleux restent plutôt bien
acceptées.
Elles sont transmises par des textes tels
que l'Histoire naturelle de Pline l'Ancien,
les Métamorphoses d'Ovide...
On y trouve des descriptions de pays où coulent
des fleuves de pierres précieuses, des ânes
marins et des hommes à tête de chien mais
ça c'est tranquille.
Pourquoi pas hein.
Faut être tolérant.
On reparlera un peu de ce merveilleux en fin
d'épisode, parce qu'il connaît un grand
regain d'intérêt au XIIIe siècle.
Avant ça on en arrive aux carolingiens, qui
continuent de supporter ces superstitions
païennes.
-Je ne veux pas vous spoiler, mais ça va
être le même refrain sur toute la période.
Bis repetita placent.
-Oui, ben, non, parce qu'il y a des nouveautés.
Sinon la vidéo serait finie.
A l'époque carolingienne, l’Église devient
maître de la culture savante.
C'est elle qui recopie les textes antiques,
donc c'est elle qui censure.
Thomas d'Aquin s'intéresse à la nature de
la superstition, la décrivant comme un péché
par excès car elle rend un culte à qui elle
ne le devrait pas, ou elle le rend mal.
C'est une démesure du culte divin, un ajout
superflu ou néfaste inspiré par le diable.
Tout ça n'empêche pas les gens de développer
de nouvelles formes de superstitions à partir
du christianisme, par exemple via le culte
des saints.
Les gens amènent des enfants malades sur
des tombeaux ou font des offrandes qui n'ont
rien à envier aux dieux païens, comme par
exemple planter des clous dans des arbres
liés aux saints.
-QUELS ARBRES?
-Nombre de ces arbres étaient mes amis.
-Le culte des saints passe par leurs reliques,
puisque l’Église admet que les saints peuvent
agir à travers elles.
Du coup, les gens plongent leur tête dans
les tombeaux des saints ou mélangent de la
poussière des tombeaux à du vin ou de l'eau
en guise de médicament.
On appelle ça le vinage, mais l’Église
craint que ce mélange soit vendu ou utilisé
à des fins magiques et non thérapeutiques.
Elle reproche aussi aux gens de vouer un culte
trop fort aux images des saints et de se détourner
trop vite d'eux si leurs vœux ne sont pas
exaucés.
A partir du IXe siècle, les textes parlent
de plus en plus de pratiques magiques et recommandent
aux prêtres de mettre en garde les fidèles
contre les sortilèges qui sont, rappelons-le,
l’œuvre du démon.
Ils visent les incantations médicales transmises
par les manuscrits antiques,
-les maléfices visant à rendre les hommes
impuissants ou au contraire à provoquer l'amour.
S'insérer un poisson dans le...
Dans le...
HMM HMM par exemple, avant de le faire manger
à son mari.
-Les maléfices visant à s'approprier des
biens, en demandant les services des faunes
et nains qui vivent dans les environs.
-Les maléfices visant à contrôler la météo,
en aspergeant une jeune fille vierge d'eau
de pluie.
A travers ces pratiques de magie blanche,
on peut observer les principales préoccupations
des habitants du Moyen Âge rural: les récoltes,
la possession de biens.
Assez peu de maléfices visent à acquérir
de l'argent, parce qu'il a peu cours dans
ces sociétés rurales.
On préfère donc demander aux faunes de voler
les biens du voisin.
Toutes ces croyances nous sont connues grâce
à des pénitentiels tels que celui de Burchard
de Worms, rédigé au XIe siècle.
Ils font la liste des pratiques condamnées
par l’Église, de manière très détaillée,
et imposent une pénitence plus ou moins lourde
selon ces pratiques.
Burchard de Worms est assez peu sévère à
l'encontre des fidèles qui se livrent à
ce genre de superstitions, parce qu'il considère
qu'il s'agit de croyances sottes ou inspirées
par...
-Le démon.
-On retrouve aussi dans ce pénitentiel des
passages repris quelques siècles plus tard
durant la chasse aux sorcières: «As-tu
partagé la croyance de certaines femmes:
que dans le silence de la nuit, portes fermées,
avec d'autres disciples du diable, tu es capable
de monter en l'air jusqu'aux nuages?»
Les sorcières ne sont d'ailleurs pas une
invention médiévale, les romains croyaient
déjà en des créatures semblables appelées
stryges.
Durant l'époque carolingienne l’Église
continue aussi son travail de remplacement
des fêtes païennes par des fêtes chrétiennes.
Un travail de longue haleine puisqu'il s'impose
dans les villes dès le Ve siècle mais dans
les campagnes, c'est pas encore ça.
On continue de fêter les lupercales même
si les gens y voient plus du folklore qu'une
vraie croyance, on fête le solstice d'été
à la place de la saint Jean...
Le culte de l'ours, très important chez beaucoup
de païens, demeure durant tout le Moyen Âge
bien que l’Église place des saints importants
sur chaque jour où c'était la fête de l'ours
auparavant.
-La fête de l'ours qui hiberne, la fête
de l'ours qui sort de sa tanière...
Au Xe siècle, le monde change, une distinction
entre le monde rural et urbain s'opère.
On passe d'un monde cléricalisé mais où
des superstitions païennes demeurent à un
monde urbain instruit d'un côté et un monde
rural un peu con de l'autre.
Ça, c'est le point de vue des urbains.
Les paysans possèdent une culture désormais
plutôt folklorique, dont certains aiment
bien se moquer.
-C'est surtout que les gens des villes ne
comprennent plus rien aux très nombreuses
croyances des paysans.
-Beaucoup d'entre elles sont compilées par
Gervais de Tilbury, un clerc du XIIe siècle.
Parmi elles on trouve beaucoup de croyances
liées aux animaux: les corneilles sont
de bons conseils, le cygne porte bonheur aux
marins, les lièvres et les chèvres sont
de mauvaise augure, la cigale favorise les
voyages...
Et puis il y a les croyances en des créatures
étranges.
Gervais de Tilbury mentionne les hommes qui
se changent en loups selon le cycle de la
lune, et dont il faut couper un membre pour
qu'ils retrouvent leur apparence.
-Il y a aussi plein d'histoires de fées,
qu'on retrouve aussi bien dans les croyances
populaires que dans la littérature savante.
Elles sont nommées parques dans l'Antiquité,
sylphes ou lamia au haut Moyen Age, dames
abondes en ancien français...
Bref, les fées ont pas mal de noms souvent
liés à la nature, l'illusion, la mort, la
noblesse et la beauté.
Elles habiteraient les champs et les forêts
et sont des personnages ni bons, ni mauvais.
-Elles apparaissent aux hommes qu'elles prennent
pour amants et leur apportent fortune, bonheur
et beaucoup d'enfants.
C'est le cas de Mélusine, dont la légende
est souvent reprise au Moyen Âge.
Tous ces bienfaits disparaissent cependant
si l'homme rompt son serment envers la fée,
qui disparaît elle aussi.
Il existerait aussi des mauvaises fées, qu'on
retrouve dans le roman du XIVe siècle Perceforest
qui inspire ensuite la Belle au Bois Dormant.
L’Église, comme d'habitude, s'interroge
sur leur nature.
Pour l'évêque Guillaume d'Auvergne, au XIIIe
siècle, les fées sont soit des démons,
soit des inventions de vieilles femmes.
Elles sont finalement intégrées à la religion
chrétienne en tant que créatures bienveillantes
quand elles servent Dieu et malveillantes
quand elles servent le diable.
Au XVe siècle leur croyance diminue, on préfère
parler de nains ou d'elfes.
-A partir de la fin du Xe siècle on parle
aussi des nicchus ou nymphes, des créatures
aquatiques d'origine scandinave à mi-chemin
entre l'homme et le cheval.
Ils seraient responsables d'inondations et
d'autres malheurs, et leur croyance entraîne
le développement du culte de saint Nicolas
qui en aurait combattus.
-Dans un registre encore plus sombre, je ne
vais pas parler des revenants parce qu'ils
ont déjà eu un épisode rien que pour eux,
mais de groupes de revenants: la Mesnie
Hellequin, aussi appelée chasse sauvage ou
armée des morts, est décrite au XIIe siècle
par Orderic Vital.
Il raconte un groupe de morts, diables, femmes,
clercs, moines, chevaliers, défilant sans
répit à travers la nuit.
Pour certains la Mesnie représente à la
fois la solidarité et la fureur des troupes
militaires.
Pour d'autres il s'agit d'un double infernal
de la société féodale, un peu comme le
monde à l'envers de Stranger Things.
Mais avec des défunts proches, puisque l'auteur
dit y avoir croisé des proches récemment
décédés le mettant en garde contre ses
péchés.
Guillaume d'Auvergne pense que ces armées
sont l’œuvre de démons, d'autres teintent
leur récit de paganisme...
Il est possible que l'apparition du Purgatoire,
à la fin du XIIe siècle, soit une réponse
à cette croyance et un moyen de trouver un
lieu pour ces revenants qui erraient sans
fin.
La mesnie disparaît des croyances à partir
du XIVe siècle.
Certains territoires ou certaines périodes
sont plus propices au surnaturel que d'autres:
la nuit est le moment où les esprits malfaisants
se manifesteraient le plus, mais en termes
géographiques ce sont les zones frontières,
à la limite du monde civilisé, qui voient
apparaître fées, nains et autres créatures.
Les frontières, les montagnes, les forêts,
les landes et la mer sont les territoires
tampon où se retrouvent la plupart des légendes.
Ces croyances ne sont pas non plus une invention
médiévale: la montagne est considérée
comme un intermédiaire entre l'homme et les
dieux chez les babyloniens, les grecs avec
l'Olympe, les juifs avec le Sinaï...
Et les chrétiens, du coup, pour qui le Paradis
se situe sur une montagne quelque part en
Orient.
Du coup je pourrais faire un épisode sur
les montagnes un jour...
Et puis, toujours au XIIe siècle, l’Église
fixe la liste de sept sacrements et en profite
pour interdire certaines pratiques peu catholiques:
danser devant les églises ou dans le cimetière,
se confesser une deuxième fois pour les même
péchés au lieu de faire sa pénitence, extorquer
des biens au mourant pendant l'extrême-onction,
ou encore baptiser des enfants dans autre
chose que de l'eau.
-Ben moi j'ions baptisé le gamin dans le
pinard.
On a toudi fait comme ça ici, ça forme ben
la jeunesse comme dit!
Et puis à partir du XIIe siècle apparaît
le merveilleux.
Le merveilleux, c'est ce qui suscite l'admiration,
l'étonnement, qui remet en cause la raison
et le quotidien.
-Vous parlez de moi?
-Mais à la différence des superstitions,
le merveilleux est 100% chrétien.
On trouve du merveilleux dans les vies de
saints, où des oiseaux apportent de la nourriture
aux hosties.
Dans la vie de tous les jours aussi: Berthe
de Bourgogne aurait ainsi accouché d'un enfant
monstrueux en punition d'avoir épousé son
cousin, Robert le Pieux.
Le merveilleux sert souvent à faire passer
un message.
On retrouve aussi largement le merveilleux
dans la littérature médiévale, à travers
des créatures, lieux ou objets magiques,
mais là on s'éloigne un peu du sujet alors
on en reparlera une autre fois.
Il n'empêche qu'on y croit, à ce merveilleux.
-Ce sont les savants antiques qui l'ont dit,
donc c'est vrai.
-On lit du merveilleux dans les traités de
géographie, les bestiaires, les encyclopédies...
Il est principalement issu des ouvrages antiques
mais est admis au Moyen Âge, ce qui permet
de faire entrer des créatures telles que
le phénix, la licorne et le dragon dans le
bestiaire médiéval.
Le merveilleux devient une petite mythologie
et contribue encore à la lutte contre les
superstitions païennes, qui sont alors remplacées.
La copie des ouvrages antiques permet qu'à
partir du XIIe siècle se forme une nouvelle
tradition orale, populaire, qui s'affranchit
des croyances antiques en formant de nouveaux
motifs comme la légende d'Arthur ou le pays
de Cocagne.
Mais lui aussi, j'en ai déjà parlé.
-Tu radotes.
La superstition a donc une définition floue:
ce qui relève de la superstition pour nous,
qui vivons dans une société plus rationnelle,
pouvait relever de la religion au Moyen Âge.
On peut diviser les superstitions au Moyen
Âge en trois périodes: le paganisme du
haut Moyen Âge, la séparation au bas Moyen
Âge entre les superstitions paysannes et
la culture savante qui adore le merveilleux
et pratique tout autant la «magie»,
mais c'est de la magie savante, et enfin les
XIVe-XVe siècle durant lesquels la superstition
n'a plus qu'une origine: le DIAAAABLE.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo! Comme
je vous le disais au début, l'épisode a
été sponsorisé par MédiMoinsQuart dont
je vais vous parler maintenant.
A la base, MédiMoinsQuart proposait des box
mensuelles de cuisine médiévale dont je
vous ai déjà un peu parlé sur Twitter.
Depuis peu, l'entreprise évolue pour proposer
des kits de cuisine médiévale, qui comprennent
toujours une recette issue de travaux de recherche
en histoire de l’alimentation, et ses ingrédients.
Ces kits seront distribués dans les boutiques
de sites historiques et des musées (MédiMoinsQuart
est d’ailleurs à la recherche de partenaires,
faites passer le mot), mais aussi sur leur
boutique en ligne où vous retrouverez également
tous les ingrédients nécessaires pour cuisiner
comme au Bas Moyen Age: épices, farines,
hydromels...
Bref.
Pour avoir testé, leurs produits sont de
qualité et leurs provenances toujours documentée.
Personnellement, j'aime, sinon j'aurais pas
fait ce partenariat.
-Oui, enfin, c'est surtout Aliénor qui a
insisté.
-Plan d'Aliénor avec sa cervoise à la main
-Bref, vous retrouverez le lien de leur site
dans la description mais aussi en bas de votre
écran en ce moment même, alors allez voir
vous-même.
Et maintenant, ben, vous pouvez commenter
ou faire un tour sur Utip et on se retrouve
le mois prochain.
Quoi qu'il se passe pas un truc spécial sur
la chaîne le mois prochain?
-Chais pô.
A toujours la cervoise à la main
-Personnellement je pars en vacances.
Dans le canapé du haut.
Ne comptez pas sur moi.
-Bon ben on verra.
J'étais sûre qu'il y avait un truc...